there's Vietnamese street food French
odd cuisine and traditional Moroccan
fare villain offers a truly vast
selection of international restaurants
the new Yura max series fifty kitchens
one city features lots of cooking great
dishes and Peaks behind the scenes to do
this he game is new it wasn't just about
cooking something it was also about
personal stories I was reminded a little
of my own family and how long I myself
have lived here in Germany and I'm in
the Familia and the language I got to be
back away on that mission also brought
me down to us I feed off the water that
was great under Spanish pitaya chin a
book of the same title was put together
while shooting for the TV series was
going on
most of the protagonists had never met
in person before the books presentation
it's a restaurant guide forbidden and
cookbook rolled into one showcasing 50
national cuisines in both German and
English each recipe comes with a QR code
that links to the corresponding cooking
video
[Music]
the German and English web pages provide
more background information the original
idea for the project came from holyshit
head of Deutsche Welle culture and
lifestyle department wouldn't it is that
the internal basic idea was of course
the international focus Berlin is home
to people from over 180 nations and
every culture has its own special taste
and unique aroma so it's only natural to
ask what all these people living
together here peacefully in Berlin have
in common each has a great cuisine and
you can discover what they all share as
well as the major differences and we
think that it's exciting I don't
articles Natasha do and just finish
Bunge
research began in April 2016 production
took about 10 months the camera team
shot more than 150 hours of material and
there was no shortage of unexpected
situations
I'm against quasi adults portable it was
definitely an enormous challenge
restaurant kitchens are often very small
we had a fairly large set in several
cameras yeah we had lights and quite a
few tripods standing around in the
kitchen this time as a relative few
stats even occur here so by the time we
set up there was hardly any room to move
around
yeah Mike Mike on the flux is to be
vegan on the best of all Christian
restaurant kitchens are also very noisy
couch couch thank you the refrigerators
and freezers are humming and we wanted
to hear the sizzling sounds of the
cooking itself so yes it was a challenge
yet as valve unify Nicosia calls for the
room today and every Friday Yura max
presents another leg in a culinary world
tour through the kitchens of Berlin